das ist wirklich verrückt an die materie
ist ja etwas ziemlich exotische so ein
seltenes eigentlich wo sie bisher nur im
labor erzeugt und ziemlich selten auch
im weltall auf gespürt aber das was
antimaterie in erheblichen mengen auf
der erde geben könnte unvorstellbar aber
es ist so in einem hurrikan wurde sogar
eine ganze lawine an antimaterie
festgestellt wort wie konnte es dazu
kommen jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction und es gibt am ende
etwas zu gewinnen 3 x 2 tickets für die
lincoln hier in berlin auf die ich mich
am wochenende auch schmuggeln werde
herzlich willkommen
erst mal wieder vielen dank für den dem
vorschlag auf whatsapp hammer kurz von
kommen bevor es um die antimaterie geht
eigentlich ist die team konnte das
festival der digital jugendkultur januar
bis 21
aber ich habe ganz doll gebettelt weil
ich es so spannend findet deshalb darf
ich jetzt hin
13 bis 21 ist eigentlich das alter und
tickets für die drei tage kosten nur 15
euro
die gibt es hier bei den condor tork und
er ist auch übrigens unten in der video
beschreibung eingeblendet und ich kann
euch nur sagen es lohnt sich mega also
drauf klicken auf den link in der video
beschreibung und mit ein bisschen glück
könnt ihr hier bei mir am ende des
videos 3 x 2 tickets gewinnen zum mega
spannenden themas ist das große rätsel
des universums warum besteht das aus
materie und nicht aus antimaterie beim
urknall entstand nämlich fast genauso
viele antimaterie materie aber eben nur
fast auf eine milliarde material die
materie paare gab es ein teilchen
materie antimaterie und materie zu
erstrahlten sich und es blieb die
materie der materie überschuss übrig
warum weiß keiner
doch es gibt antimaterie in geringen
mengen im universum zum beispiel in
gewittern watch schon vor einigen jahren
konnten forschungsteams mit hilfe des
fermi teleskops verdächtigen signale
auffangen
sie richteten dafür den fermi satelliten
richtung erde
er sollte gammablitze also energiereiche
elektromagnetische strahlung in
gewittern untersuchen
ja und er stieß auf etwas absolut
verblüffendes antimaterie die vermutung
blitze produzieren nicht nur
energiereiche strahlung sondern lösen
auch kernreaktionen in der umgebenden
luft aus die vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler bei
dieser zerfallsreaktionen wird
antimaterie frei es entstehen sogenannte
positronen also quasi positiv geladene
elektronen und zwar wenn energiereiche
gammablitze auf atomkerne treffen denn
dann kann ein antiteilchen paar
entstehen also ein elektron materie und
ein positron antimaterie jetzt haben
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
erstmalig die schauer der sogenannten
positronen direkt im gewitter gemessen
sie flogen durch den inneren wolken
des hurrikans patricia schon vor drei
jahren jetzt wurden die ergebnisse
veröffentlicht und das ist wirklich irre
nicht ein oder ein paar teilchen
antimaterie sondern ganze schauer
das wiederum bestätigt wiederum die
theoretische vorhersage die bislang über
die hoch energetischen vorgängen in den
wolken existieren demnach entstehen die
schauer von positronen also positiv
geladenen elektronen wenn hoch
energetische gammablitze durch gewitter
erzeugt werden konkret konnte das
messinstrument namens adele in einer
höhe von etwa 200 kilometern das signal
eines hoch energetischen teilchen
strahls auffangen zudem wurden auch
blitze über dem flugzeug registriert
dass die positronen nun direkt
beobachtet werden konnten ist wie gesagt
eine absolute sensation eine echte
premiere
doch wie entstehen sie genau nach einem
modell dazu durch den mechanismus des
sogenannten relativistischen feedbacks
in den gewitterwolken befindet sich ein
elektrisches feld das die darin
enthaltenen elektron beschleunigt je
schneller sie werden umso weniger
luftwiderstand gibt es eine positive
rückkopplung quasi die zu einer lawine
von elektronen führt und zwar fast alle
so schnell wie das licht diese wiederum
schicken hoch energetische
gammastrahlung zum himmel
zudem und das ist das irre werden paare
aus elektronen und positronen gebildet
genauso wie die elektronen werden die
positronen vom elektrischen feld
beschleunigt doch eben einen unterschied
gibt es sie werden in die
entgegengesetzte richtung geschleudert
sie sind ja auch positiv geladen nämlich
zum boden und so konnten sie überhaupt
auch erst vom agilität act or aufgespürt
werden ja und jetzt könnt ihr die themen
contacts gewinnen meldet euch bei
whatsapp an und schreibt mir wie das
festival der jugendkultur am wochenende
in berlin heißt gibt es mehrere richtige
antworten entscheidet das los die
gewinnspielbedingungen sind in der video
beschreibung verlinkt klicks also hier
drauf und am besten auch meine schwester
cara klicks um social and media
abonnieren da erfahrt ihr das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken
aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
kräftig
so kann antimaterie erzeugt werden bis
dann bleibt dran